all right are you brush runner I can't
hear ya does [ __ ] me here we go
[ __ ] [ __ ] diet Adam [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me you say it oven job piss you did
it yeah [ __ ] idiot I just oh my god
hey my name's Barry today we're gonna
play Peter Cook to apply to we're doing
this episode live okay without further
ado let's Oh God begin okay
level three this is beautiful it's
soothing it can't be that bad
I can jump on this yes okay now [ __ ] me
that's actually scared me Jesus Christ
yes how does that kill me why I can't
touch the ground how does it work what
is this
how does everything kill me okay we're
good
I have to stand on this def block got it
alright let's how I don't understand
god damn this was a terrible idea okay
wait now it's shook time I just happened
oh I miss I miss missed miss me [ __ ]
yes oh the mushrooms kill me I got it
jump on that jump here don't jump on the
mushrooms
y'all gotta ride in my popper people say
Oh God [ __ ] me in the ass
alright I'm not even pissed I feel
pretty good I feel pretty confident that
we can do it up calm down ahh ahh
god damn it God [ __ ] me I jumped on him
how here we go yes
oh hello MLG beat yes yes yes yeah why
do I get scared oh my god [ __ ] man
alright here we go yeah hot you brush
think you can do better
alright now we just need to get up there
nailed it I like the music it's very now
oh god what are you alone dear I come in
peace yes don't kill me please place
okay me I have feelings
I think it's it's peaceful okay
mmm this grass the sweet-ass grass
tastes amazing
oh hi stranger I suggest you bring a
sick with you they say it brings luck
well [ __ ] you you can't tell me what to
do
[ __ ]
I saw this stick but we're not gonna get
it you can never trust a stick unless
it's your own oh god what is happening
I'm pretty sure if I move I'm gonna die
but I think I got him taunted with my
pooper I'm scared I'm scared Bruce I
don't know what to do
no okay let's bring the moose it's stick
all right I can easily do this look at
this [ __ ] look at it [ __ ] boy you think
I don't know how to play [ __ ] games
and [ __ ] give me that [ __ ] you oh [ __ ]
ah what the [ __ ] was that how the [ __ ]
does the stick bring luck that [ __ ] is
lying okay [ __ ] the stick look at that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you lying son of
a [ __ ] how am I supposed to jump
through those yeah ah why the hell am I
going I known about is known [ __ ] it's
so hard that job ah that's okay I can do
it I know I can do it but like maybe I
need to get the stick you know what I
changed my [ __ ] you oh I got the stick
good job don't tell me to calm down
gross all right we got the stick
ha ha ha ha yes we did it I brought you
in a stick I admit I would have done the
same
yeah I think you will have it easier for
now on I will just continue eating grass
since that is what I like to do if you
know what I mean
holy [ __ ] I can see okay alright okay
there we go
how is it easier oh oh I get it the
monster didn't chase me today
okay wait for it then thin then bin jump
hit yeah oh I did it no oh god damn it
[ __ ] I tried so hard go
nah-nah
yes yes yes yes jump jump jump
wha oh oh oh gee uh I keeps coming it's
kept me at it
ah alright well I definitely don't trust
that [ __ ]
I think I need a jump on him to get up
though okay here we go pull there boom
there smooth like smooth that damn it
that wasn't my only chance wasn't it I
can do it alright I could totally do it
what the [ __ ] woo okay but what [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
you can't just appear out of nowhere
that's not smooth like smoother you're
kidding me
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me I'm done
Oh fine you know what fine
only for you breasts yes look at this
I'm gonna do it faultlessly ah MLG
[ __ ] suck my duck ass duck ass
duck ass duck oh are you [ __ ] kidding
me
ah oh [ __ ]
I'm an Evo hell
see I don't even give a [ __ ] oh
yeah no I don't care
literally don't care um ya know don't
care yeah Tommy victim I just want to
live don't really care about what Alan
oh yeah just blame the game pants [ __ ]
you don't tell me watch it I know
exactly how to play games I play games
all day all night son
oh my god funny go many bought a fetus
yeah ah this is supposed to be the easy
map the ec map they said well where's my
[ __ ] checkpoint then mate for the
brush and my house
good job pursued edit your [ __ ] idiot
I'm legit just focused on doing this
[ __ ] now
Mandy what's my mother okay
all right I remember now there was
something I needed to get I think we
need to jump on him yes
you [ __ ] [ __ ] what oh yeah yeah
am I supposed to go down here maybe I'm
supposed to go down Bruce what do you
think
Bruce what do you think answer me light
light right now live in the comments
tell me what do I do
should I continue or jump down continue
or jump down I need to know fine
like my mom once said if you're not a
bro yeah and you got it yo lo well my
mom my mom betrayed me I knew it I knew
it I knew it
see I know how to play games [ __ ] feet
does weave [ __ ] me every cow
[ __ ] think that was a sentence
Oh feet die rabbit I just oh my god this
is my moment feet dieter then yeah
[ __ ] come back here okay okay oh
gotta get pumped oh all right we're
gonna jump over good all right now what
I don't is that Edgar what's that ended
in a barrel goddamn it and get I knew
you couldn't be trusted
hook Adam scared I'm [ __ ] scared go
in
Oh God oh my dick Oh my deck
Oh God all right come at me bro Oh God
no we got this [ __ ] Browse button yeah
yeah ah Vic does you have the love feet
that guy I hate you have you [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill ya I'm gonna [ __ ]
stuff you up [ __ ] all right okay I'm
gonna duck underneath him suck a dick
suck a huge come back here oh god I'm
scared
I did it okay okay okay there's a chance
what there's double a cure you can't
just [ __ ] double anchor me
you can't just [ __ ] double Edgar me
yeah oh [ __ ] my ass come on huh okay
okay
Oh double dagger where the [ __ ] is Maya
ha ha ha ha huh hey what do I do now
what the [ __ ] do i do what do i do what
do I do
Oh God Lord Matthew are you listening
hello I'm Matthew oh you're there please
give me a message I just want to make it
to the next checkpoint that's all I want
diamonds and [ __ ] I don't need them I
just want your blessing thank you
please bless me bless me with your
diamond color curls
Matthew place if you can hear this
there's two me and a couple thousand for
us would really appreciate your help
okay now what the [ __ ] do I do this is
the joke listen this a joke is this a
joke cause I'm not laughing place Lord
Matthew I don't think I can handle I
don't think I can handle it Lord Matthew
do you want me to kill myself Matthew is
that what you are I'm gonna count down
from 10 and then we're gonna jump on
zero okay here comes for us are you with
me
alright 10 9 8 7 6 5 oh yeah why Lord
Matthew Oh
blow your bridge well I hope you enjoyed
this dream I'm gonna go and [ __ ] off all
right breasts
I gotta end that episode there I don't
think I can handle it I am sorry I tried
I [ __ ] tried thank you for leaving a
like and showing your support and thank
you for watching my videos I really
appreciate it
I'll see you bros I'm sure we can do it
I'll see you brothers in the next one
stay awesome